- Michel Collon, bonjour.
- Bonjour.
- Nous vous recevons aujourd’hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui s’appelle Thinkerview.
On aurait voulu avoir votre regard sur la géopolitique actuelle, qu’est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire ?
Première question, qui êtes-vous ?
- Je suis écrivain et journaliste indépendant,
en-dehors du système des médias.
J’ai commencé à travailler après une carrière comme – une carrière, c’est un vilain mot –
comme journaliste sur les luttes sociales en Belgique, puisque je suis basé à Bruxelles – ou à Liège
et j’ai commencé à travailler sur
ce qui est devenu mon thème central :
les guerres, les stratégies de guerre et les stratégies de désinformation,
pour moi ça va ensemble, avec un livre qui s’appelait « Attention médias » sur la 1ere guerre du Golfe contre l’Irak.
« Attention médias » évidemment je ne me suis pas fait que des amis,
encore qu’il y a eu un intérêt de la part de certains services publics,
on va dire, surtout.
Vous savez en 90-91, ça a été le festival des médias-mensonges et de la désinformation.
Autour de la guerre d'Irak ?
- Au cours de la guerre d’Irak ; les couveuses volées dans une maternité c’était bidon,
Saddam Hussein avait provoqué une marée noire, et Michel Chevalet sur TF1
présenté par Poivre d’Arvor disait « Regardez Saddam Hussein comme il est méchant,
il a fait délibérément envahir le Golfe, là, par une marée noire de pétrole … ».
- Vous pouvez déléguer l’histoire des bébés dans les couveuses ?
- Les bébés dans les couveuses, c’était ceci : ça se passait en novembre 90,
et à une commission d’enquête dépendant du congrès aux États-Unis,
il y a une jeune fille de 15 ans qui vient témoigner en disant « Voilà » (elle pleure toute les larmes de son corps) et elle dit :
« J’étais infirmière à Koweït City, la capitale occupée alors par les troupes Irakiennes depuis 3 mois,
et je travaille dans cette maternité  et un jour les soldats Irakiens sont venus, ils ont pris toutes les couveuses, il y en avait 32
et ils ont jeté les bébés par terre et comme c’étaient des prématurés, forcément ils étaient condamnés à une mort atroce
et donc voilà … les Irakiens c’est vraiment une occupation épouvantable, il faut faire quelque chose. »
- Et la jeune fille son père c’était qui ?
- La jeune fille, donc … Forcément c’est une histoire qui a été popularisée, Mitterrand en a parlé, Bush en a parlé,
Amnesty a fait des rapports, « Le vol des couveuses » c’était donc un argument de choc
choc pour dire « Il faut aller écraser ce Saddam Hussein qui n’épargne même pas les bébés ».
Après la guerre, évidemment tous les journalistes quand le Koweït est libéré de l’occupation,
on va dire, tous les journalistes se précipitent à la maternité, « On va avoir un scoop, On va avoir les confidences
de tous ces médecins qui ont assisté à ça » … et les médecins disent : « Nos couveuses elles sont là,
il s’est rien passé…». Il s’est rien passé du tout.
La jeune fille était en fait la fille de l’ambassadeur du Koweït à Washington,
elle était pas plus infirmière que vous et moi, elle avait passé ses dernières années là, avec son père…
Et c’était une totale mise en scène par une firme de « public relations » qui s’appelle Hill & Knowlton.
Il y en a toute une série aux États-Unis qui font ça. Et en fait c’est quoi, c’est des firmes de com
qui se chargent de donner une image positive à des gouvernements étrangers
Israël fait ça, l’Arabie Saoudite fait ça, l’Afrique du Sud faisait ça au temps de l’apartheid, et le Koweït faisait ça.
Evidemment, donner une image positive du Koweït c’était pas évident
donc on a plutôt fait dans la diabolisation de Saddam Hussein et on a complètement fabriqué cette histoire
des couveuses volées. Et ça c’est un festival de média-mensonges que j’ai résumé dans ce bouquin.
On était en 91, c'était le point de départ de mon travail là-dessus.
- Après 91, vous vous êtes arrété sur quoi ?
Après il y a eu la guerre contre la Yougoslavie en 2 phases
D'abord en Croatie, Bosnie de 91 à 95 puis en 99, la guerre soit disant pour libérer le Kosovo
Et en réalité pour détruire la Yougoslavie qui était un pays indépendant
Une armée indépendant qui ne voulait pas entrer dans l'OTAN
Et un pays où il y avait pas mal de choses qui n'allaient pas mais aussi des choses qui allaient pas mal
Et notamment une sécurité sociale important, une sécurité d'emplois
Dans les entreprises les travailleurs élisaient leur directeur donc ca quand les multinationales
Quand il y a eu la chute du mur, du socialisme à l'est, la Yougoslavie était le seul pays qui résistait
qui ne se mettait pas à genoux devant les multinationales donc j'ai montré dans 2 livres : "Poker menteur" et "Monopoly, l'Otan à la conquète du monde"
qu'en faite c'était une guerre de recolonisation d'une zone qui avait été perdue
et donc moi je travail sur cela, sur ce thème la, j'avais pas prévu au départ de faire ça
Mais le livre "Attention média" à très très bien marché,
c'était la première fois qu'on faisait une analyse critique de média en Europe.
Il y avait eu aux États-Unis, Edward Herman et Noam Chomsky,
qui avaient publié un bouquin qui m'avait inspiré, très important
qui s'appelle "Manufactoring consent", la fabrication du consentement.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils avaient fait un genre de test-média, ils analysaient la couverture
des 2 camps dans les grands médias des États-Unis.
Quantitativement déjà, et puis aussi qualitativement dans l'analyse, ça m'avait inspiré
et j'avais décidé d'appliquer ça à cette guerre du golfe en 90-91
et après comme ça a eu beaucoup de succès, beaucoup d'impact les gens étaient très curieux
sur justement "Est-ce que les médias me manipulent ?". A ce moment là les États-Unis n'ont pas
arrêté de me donner du travail puisque à cette époque là on nous avait annoncé
un nouvel ordre mondial, il n'y aura plus de guerre, etc, et depuis les guerres ne se sont pas arrêtées
et donc j'ai couvert ça, puis la Libye,  puis d'autres et c'est devenu un peu ma spécialité
de base comme écrivain on va dire, les stratégies et la propagande de guerre.
- Que pouvez-vous me dire de Carl Von Clausewitz ?
J'en suis pas un spécialiste, je vois que la guerre se déroule sur différents terrains mais en fait,
moi je dis toujours les guerres ne commencent pas par des bombes mais par des média-mensonges
et je pense qu'il y a maintenant du coté des États-Unis, une stratégie de guerre globale
la guerre se déroule en réalité face à l'ennemi direct déclaré
on va protéger des minorités, écarter un danger terroriste
mais en réalité il faut viser, pas seulement comme le prétendent les dirigeants
il faut viser la population qui n'a pas forcement envie d’être colonisée ou recolonisée
et puis il faut viser l'opinion publique internationale
et donc pour que les États-Unis ou la France en Afrique puissent déclencher une guerre
le premier ennemi est l'opinion publique intérieure, il faut absolument la neutraliser
il faut l'empecher de s'opposer à cette guerre, car quand on regarde dans le passé il y a eu beaucoup
de guerres qui ont été arrétées ou freinées par la résistance internationale
dans ma génération, on a été marqués par l'agression des États-Unis contre le Vietnam
qui a commencé en 61 jusqu'en 75 et elle a été freiné pourquoi ? Les États-Unis avaient mis le paquet
c'était à l’époque la plus grande puissance économique financière, militaire
de l'histoire on peut dire, il y avait jamais eu un arsenal militaire pareil
et le Vietnam était un pays pauvre de paysans, très peu développé, a cause du colonialisme
et donc à la fin c'est David qui à gagné et Goliath qui est parti la queue entre les jambes
parce que quand les Vietnamiens étaient bien soudés on va dire, avec des dirigeants honnête ça compte beaucoup
pas corrompus avec une vision de la libération, une vision d'unir toutes les forces
possibles, les communistes, les bouddhistes, les chrétiens,
des différentes classes sociales contre l'occupation et 2 le facteur qui a permis que les États-Unis
soient vaincus c'est la mobilisation internationale, on faisait des manifs contre la guerre
au début il y avait que quelques centaines de personnes puis finalement des manifs de centaines de milliers de personnes
et les États-Unis ont été complétement démasqués là-dessus
- Que pouvez-vous nous dire sur l'affaire du Golfe du Tonkin ?
- Intéressant ça, moi je dis que chaque guerre commencent pas par des bombes mais par des média-mensonges
et dans le cas de la baie du Tonkin
les États-Unis, c'était Johnson je pense à l'époque, avaient décidé d'intensifier
leurs opérations et ils ont dit "Voilà les 2 navires US dans la baie du Tonkin
ont été attaqués par les Vietnamiens et donc nous ripostons" ; c'est un classique de la propagande de guerre
c'est jamais nous qui attaquons c'est les méchants et nous on est en légitime défense
et après les États-Unis ont reconnu que l'incident de la baie du Tonkin avait été complètement fabriqué de toutes pièces
chaque guerre est basée sur un média-mensonge et ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai analysé pour l'Irak
pour la Yougoslavie, pour la Libye, un gros truc qui est monopolisé dans la communication de guerre
et qui doit faire basculer l'opinion, oui il faut faire quelque chose.
- Est-ce que vous avez entendu parler de l'opération Northwoods ?
- Oui c'est avec l'Irak ça ? avec le Contragate ?
- C'est à peu près la même époque, avec Cuba, je mettrai les liens.
Très bien donc les média-mensonges à la base d'une guerre sont pour retourner l'opinion pulique.
On est en 2016, que relevez-vous actuellement comme média-mensonges ?
Il y a 2 choses: 1 - On répète les médias mensonges des guerres pécédentes
qui ont pourtant été complètement démasqués et ça c'est frappant, sur la Libye par exemple
que j'ai suivi car j"ai été 2 fois là-bas par exemple
pendant les bombardements, j'ai fais une enquête, un livre qui s'appelle
"Libye, OTAN et média-mensonges" et là moi je disais à l'époque
1) c'est basé sur des médias mensonges d'origine à savoir que Kadafi aurait bombardé la population
qui manifestait ce qui est totalement faux, c'était une invention
2), qu'il aurait envoyé des containers de Viagra pour stimuler ses soldats pour violer en masse comme
instrument de terreur de la population, les viols de guerre c'est un classique de la progande de guerre
évidemment quand j'ai été en Libye et que j'ai raconté cette histoire ils m'ont ri au nez
en disant nous viagra on connait pas c'est le gingembre et c'était complètement bidon
et ça c'est au niveau des média-mensonges justificateurs et puis j'ai dis à l'époque dans les premiers articles
et puis il y a eu ce livre j'ai dis c'est une guerre évidemment pour le pétrole de Kadafi
c'est une guerre pour les réserves très importantes, il y avait 30 milliards de revenus chaque années
du pétrole, pour des pays en crise comme les USA et la France c'est un buttin, j'ai dis c'est l'or de Kadafi
qui est placé dans les banques des États-Unis et qui ne vont jamais rendre
et c'est pour empêcher Kadafi ne financer des projets de développement alternatif de pays Africain
pour échapper au chantage des multinationales et du FMI.
Evidemment on m'a dit c'est un comploteur, il voit le mal partout
bien sûr que les États-Unis et Sarko font une guerre humanitaire
et maintenant dans les e mails révélés de Mme Clinton, elle dit : "oui Sarko il faisait la guerre car
il voulait le pétrole et il avait des accords pour Total, et 2 c'est une bonne raison de faire la guerre à Kadafi
pour son or
- Combien représentait l'or de Kadafi ?
- C'est des sommes très importantes, car la Libye était je n'ai plus les chiffres, c'est dans mon bouquin
pour une raison très simple, la Libye était l'un des rares pays du monde sans dettes
- Certes l'or était intérréssant mais moi j'ai suivi l'aspect
plutôt sur les fonds souverain qui représentent plus en masse de dollars qu'en réalité de l'or physique
le fond souverain Libyen d'investissement étranger était beaucoup plus important (- oui oui absolument)
La Syrie, que pouvez-vous nous dire ?
- C'est quelque chose qu'on a suivi sur le site Investig action notamment en publiant les enquêtes
de Bahar Kimyongür qui est un Belge d'origine Turque mais de la communauté proche de la Syrie
qui a suivi ce dossier en permanance, et en fait, oui on a eu comme d'habitude
des média-mensonges pour justifier une guerre qu'il voulait mener contre la Syrie
mais par des méthodes indirectes et les média-mensonges c'était notamment
de montrer des cadavres et des choses bien atroces comme on fait toujours dans chaque guerre
pour jouer sur les émotions du public et de dire voilà c'est Bachar qui l'a fait
et dans beaucoup de cas de photos qui ont été publiées, c'était l"inverse.
Je ne dis pas que les troupes de Bachar ce sont des anges toujours, il y a eu des atrocités
des crimes c'est incontestable, mais très souvent on montrait des photos en disant, voilà les victimes de Bachar
mais c'était des soldats tués par les rebelles justement
ça c'est très frappant. Au niveau des armes chimiques, personne n'est des anges dans ce conflit
mais il faut toujours voir à qui profite ce genre de chose
le moment où ça se passe, c'est le moment où l'opposition rebelle est en grande difficulté
sur le plan militaire, c'est le moment où la Syrie aaccepté que vienne une mission de l'ONU
pour une mission de bon office pour mettre fin au conflit et juste à ce moment là comme par hasard
sous les yeux des inspecteurs Bachar aurait été utiliser des armes chimiques
à quelques kilomètre de l'endroit où ils sont, ça c'est un truc classique
en réalité il y a eu beaucoup de documents des USA et notamment de Seymour Hersh
qui est un journaliste d'Investig'action important aux USA, qui beaucoup de confidences
de l'etabishment militaire, qui a dit non non ça c'est complètement bidon
- Vous parlez des USA, est ce que vous avez suivi l'affaire de l'anthrax, des mails d'anthrax ?
- Oui, les principes de la propagande de guerre c'est de cacher l'histoire, cacher les intêrets économiques
diaboliser, effrayer, inverser l'agresseur et l'agréssé, monopoliser le débat
censurer les informations adverses, dans la diabolisation il faut absolument flanquer la trouille.
C'est quelque chose que Michael Moore a bien montré
dans Bowling for Columbine
qui montre que Bush dans sa croisade, qui voulait attaquer beaucoup plus de pays que ce qu'il a fait
il avait vraiment besoin de flanquer la trouille aux citoyens des USA avec le terrorisme
et évidemment ce cinéma sur l'anthrax et sur les armes de destructions massives
tout ça c'est au même moment, ce sont des recettes
je parlais des public relation, il y a "psyops" en Grande bretagne et aux États-Unis
là c'est même assez ouvert, des experts de la manipulation psychologique
et ces gens là sont des pros, c'est-à-dire qu'ils analysent quels sont les thèmes qui peuvent marcher
pour flanquer la trouille ou pour justifier une guerre
je sais pas si vous avez vu un film qui s'appelle Wag the Dog
qui est un film très intérréssant, où un président, déjà dans les années 90 je crois
un président est en déclin dans les sondages, il a couché avec une fille
il faut absolument qu'il remonte dans les sondages, donc ces experts en communication
décident: il faut un ennemi, le problème c'est qu'il n'y a aucune tension particulière
il y a pas de gros conflits, donc on va fabriquer un ennemi
et qu'elle pays ce peut être ? non pas celui la
et donc on décide finalement que ça va être l'Albanie, pas grand monde connait on sait même pas ou s'est
et donc on va pouvoir fabriqué, c'est De Niro ou Hoffman
il y a donc un scénariste d'Hollywwod qui est chargé de fabriqué, il invente des images
où on voit une petite fille avec une flamme derrière et un pauvre petit chat, c'est tourner en studio
mais c'est présenté comme la pauvre petite fille qui échappe aux atrocités des méchants
il faut que les USA aillent protéger cette pauvre petite et son chat
le film montre vraiment la fabrication de l'ennemi et bien évidemment à la fin le scénariste est assassiné
car il faut pas que ça se sache, le président remonte dans les sondages et le scénariste doit mourrir
- Au mileu de toute cette propagande de guerre, comment se situe la France ?
Vous avec votre nationalité Belge, comment vous nous voyez ?
- Les Français ça n'existe pas, je sais pas si vous parlez de Hollande, Valls ou BHL
ou si vous parlez des gens qu'on vient de rencontrer dans la rue, pour moi je pense que malheureusement
les Français ont un gouvernement qui gouverne contre leurs intérêts.
- Quels sont les intérêts des Français ?
Les intérêts des Français c'est d'avoir du travail, un revenu correct
pouvoir donner un avenir à ses enfants, se payer des soins de santé, et avoir une vie un peu correcte
ce qui est financièrement et techniquement tout à fait possible
il y a bien assez de richesse qui sont produites pour que tout le monde vive bien
on est dans une situation abominable maintenant
la moitié des gens travaillent comme des dingues, sont stréssés, font des heures supp
et prennent des pilules pour tenir le coup et l'autre moitié sont au chômage, sous-employés,
prennent des pilules parce qu'ils sont en déprime, il faut absolument organiser la vie économique
et sociale en fonction des besoins des gens et pas au profit de quelques multinationales
ça c'est un système infernal, l’intérêt des Français, Belges comme tout le monde
c'est de vivre bien, de vivre correctement, il y a des déjà une première mesure qui devrait être faite
puisqu'il y a pas du travail pour tout le monde, car heureusement les techniques, les technologies
l'informatique ont progressé, on doit travailler beaucoup moins qu'avant, donc on partage le travail
tout le monde travaille 20h, tout le monde sera content, et on pourra s'occuper de ses gosses
de la culture, voyager, faire du sport, des choses qu'on a envie, ça c'est l’intérêt des gens
- Un jour je discutait avec quelqu'un qui est censé avoir un cerveau bien fait
il m'a dit "Tu sais la démographie nuit à la qualité des cerveaux" ; qu'en pensez-vous ?
- Il veut dire que si on fabrique trop de gosses on sera plus bête ?
Je n'ai pas la réponse il faudra lui demander à lui, mais pour revenir à la question importante
l'intérêt des Français n'est pas le même que l'intérêt des 1% qui accumule des fortunes
je pense à *CENSURE* qui pille l'Afrique, qui s'est fabriqué une fortune là dessus.
je pense à des gens comme *CENSURE* qui licencie à tour de bras et accumule des fortunes
dont ils savent pas quoi faire, l'intérêt des 99% est exactement contraire aux intérêts du 1%
et on a de plus en plus de fortune, on a 85 personnes qui possèdent autant que la moitié de l'humanité
c'est un système absurde, ça ne peut pas continuer, les gens ne peuvent pas petre heureux dans un système comme cela
et le problème c'est que les guerres sont des guerres pour la 1% car qui a intérêt d'aller controler
les minerais en Afrique, le pétrole au moyen Orient, les marchés, les forêts, l'eau,
qui a intérêt ? Vous ? moi ? Non. On peut très bien vivre avec ce qu'il y a ici et en ayant des relations normales
équitables, fraternelles avec les autres peuples. Mais les gens qui ont besoin de toujours plus de fric
pas pour le plaisir ou parce qu'ils sont méchants mais s'il le font pas le concurrent va les éliminer
Regardez toutes ces fusions de multinationales, toutes ces boîtes dont l'unique obssession
c'est d'être le meilleur, éliminer les autres, les avaller et d'être toujours plus gros, ça sert à quoi ?
Ca sert à produire des trucs inutiles, de gaspiller les ressources de la nature et à rendre les gens malheureux
soit parce qu'ils travaillent trop soit parce qu'ils ont pas de travail, c'est ça qui doit changer.
Et les guerres sont malheureusement une manière de faire main basse sur les matières premières
les marchés, la main d'oeuvre aussi donc c'est des guerres pour le 1%
- Donc comment se positionne la France autour de tout ca ? La France est suiviste ?
Elle essaye de faire entendre sa voix ?
- Est-ce que c'est une question importante ? C'est une question d'un Français
En fait l'élite Française a 2 tendances, il y a une tendance qui voudrait bien
garder son pré carré en Afrique, sa zone d'influence et qui essayerait d'être plus indépendante
par rapport aux USA, dans le sens qu'il y a eu un moment donné
des tendances en France et en Allemagne à faire une euro-armée
qui serait indépendante de l'OTAN et ça j'en ai parlé dans le livre "Monopoly : l'OTAN à la conquête du Monde"
que les Etats-Unis - il y a eu des textes de Paul Wolfowitz, il y a eu des textes de Richard Perle etc,
de Zbigniew Brzezinski aussi, qui disaient : "Il faut absolument empêcher l'Europe d'avoir son armée et d'être indépendante."
D'ailleurs la guerre contre la Yougoslavie dont on a parlé toute à l'heure, c'était pas seulement une guerre contre ce pays
c'était une guerre pour empêcher la France de s'entendre avec l'Allemagne, avec la Russie
pour que l'Europe devienne indépendante donc il y a cette tendance là dans l'élite Française
et il y a aussi la tendance Sarko, Hollande tout ça, qui s'est complètement alignée sur les Etats-Unis,
complètement j'exagère, mais qui pense qu'en étant le numéro 2 là-dedans il y aura des bons morceaux
du gâteau à récupérer, en quoi ils se font les doigts dans l'oeil parce que quand la France possède et contrôle une colonie
des richesses en Afrique, les États-Unis financent des politiques et surtout des mouvements pour déclencher des guerres civiles
et destabiliser ça, les États-Unis font semblant d'être allié avec la France en Afrique mais en réalité il l'a poignarde
dans le dos régulièrement
- Comment se comportent les médias ? il y a bien une analyse médiatique ?
On a compris que ces médias-mensonges seraient ou semblent être construits par des cabinets spécialisés ou de propagande médiatique payés
Le journaliste du service public Belge, Francais, Portugais, Espagnol, il se comporte comment face à cela ?
- La question elle porte sur les médias ou journalistes ?
- Les deux.
- Ce n'est pas du tout la même chose, les journalistes, est-ce que c'est eux qui décident dans les médias ?
Je fais toujours la disctinction, je crois qu'il y a différentes catégories de journalistes
Il y en a de très curieux, honnêtes qui essayeraient vraiment de faire passer des choses
le problème c'est que dans les médias ce n'est pas le journaliste qui ont le pouvoir
c'est le patron tout simplement comme dans toute entreprise et il faut voir qu'au niveau
international et français c'est très clair, qui possède les grands quotidien ou les grandes télés ?
Ce sont tous des milliardaires, vous avez *CENSURE*, marchand d'armes
*CENSURE* pilleur de l'Afrique, *CENSURE* marchand d'arme
*CENSURE*, une des personnes les plus riche en Israel,  donc l'info que les gens reçoivent
que les 99% recoivent, sont fait par les 1% pour leurs intérêts, alors vous allez me dire c'est pas parce qu'il est patron
qu'il va mettre le journaliste à la porte, bah si, on a pleins d'exemple justement où des journalistes
n'ont pas pu exprimé ou on carrément été viré, un exemple qui n'est pas révolutionnaire de gauche
dans Paris Match, quand Genestar y était rédac chef ou directeur à l'époque
publie des photos montrant que la femme de Sarko n'est pas allée votée à la fameuse élection présidentielle de 2007
ce qui est franchement une info un peu anecdotique mais viré pour ca car Sarko téléphone
et indirectement le patron vire
-Il y a eu des preuves de cela ?
Oui oui ca été reconnu
Donc c'est le patron qui décide mais l'analyse est que l'info elle est filtrée de différentes manières
il n'y a pas que la propriété, il a aussi la publicité, c'est à dire que maintenant vous pouvez lancer un quotidien
mais supposons qu'on le vende 1€-1€50 en réalité le coup de fabrication est 2 à 3 fois plus important
ca veut dire que ce n'est pas en payant le quotidien que vous le payé, c'est l'annonceur qui paye le quotidien
on vend un acheteur à un annonceur, et le budget de la publicité c'est quoi ? c'est le pétrole
c'est les bagnoles, tout ces machins la, pas le coiffeur du coin qui fait vivre les grands journaux ou la téé
donc la publicité est un filtre très important, le troisième filtre important ce sont les relations entre les pouvoirs
économiques, politiques, et médiatiques. Il y a un très bon bouquin
malheureusement épuisé de Geoffrey Geuens "Tous pouvoirs confondus"
où il analyse tout les grandes multinationales Européennes et des États-Unis
et il montre l’enchevêtrement au niveau des actionnaires et au niveau des administrateurs
vraiment toutes les multinationales sont les unes dans les autres et au niveau des médias c'est très frappant
j'ai publié dans un de mes bouquins, un résumé de ce qu'il avait travaillé et qui montre que dans les médias
aux États-Unis, on a les multinationales de la banque, de la chimie, du pétrole, de l'armement, etc
qui sont dans les médias, donc on a des relations très très etroites et puis il y a des copinages
et d'élitisme entre les grands directeurs et les journalistes vedettes
et les pouvoirs politiques et économiques et le 4ème filtre ne doit pas être négligé
c'est la question de l'idéologie dominante parce que je n'ai pas voulu dire et je ne dirai jamais
"tous les journalistes sont pourris", plein de journalistes essayent de faire correctement leur travail
1, en général on leur laisse pas le temps d'investiguer sur des enquêtes, il faut
produire vite, c'est un travail à la chaîne en fait et 2 il y a aussi ce phénomène de l'idéologie
on vit dans une société, où on a été formé dans l'école, les journalistes baignent aussi dans l'info qui est diffusée
et ça c'est une idéologie dominante. Un journaliste vedette de TF1 disait au moment de la guerre du Golfe
disait on a d'un coté le monde civilisé et de l'autre coté le monde Arabe, textuellement à l'antenne
donc on est dans une pensée extrêmement raciste et colonialiste ça restera très fort
Régis Debray avait dit cette phrase que j'aime beaucoup citer, parlant justement de ce phénomène
il disait : "Ils ont enlevé leurs casques mais dessous leur tête est restée coloniale."
Le mode de pensée reste celui de l'Européen blanc supérieur avec ses valeurs et que les arabes
les noirs doivent apprendre de l'Européen civilisé
- Sur votre chaine youtube vous avez annoncé il y a 1-2 mois que Laurent Fabius et le gouvernement
de François Hollande étaient responsable des attentats avec le Bataclan, je crois bien, par le fait qu'il ai financé le terrorisme
- Oui ça ne vient pas de moi, ça vient de différents enquêteurs dont de nouveau Seymour Hersh
un journaliste très intéressant qui devrait vraiment être diffusé parce qu'il a les confidences de gens de l'Etablishment
par exemple quand Obama ou Clinton décide d'une guerre, vous avez des généraux qui ne sont pas d'accord
qui disent on ne peut pas la gagner, ca va provoquer des effets pires et donc qui balancent des choses
et donc Seymour Hersh avait effectivement fait des révélations par rapport à tout cela.
- La question était pourquoi vous incriminiez Laurent Fabius dans les attentats ?
- Et donc lui Seymour Hersh a annoncé en fait que ce qu'on a appelé les euro-djihadistes
ces jeunes qui partent se battre en Syrie, le mot djihad ne convient pas car dans le Coran cela signifie le combat
avec soi-même pour être un homme plus juste donc ça n'a rien à voir
mais ces jeunes qui ont été envoyés là-bas, ça a été un travail organisé
par la CIA, avec des camps d'entraînement, il a donné des dates, le nom des lieux et même les instructeurs.
Ca a été financé par l'Arabie Saoudite et la Qatar, nos chers amis investisseurs dans notre économie, dans nos
clubs sportif et dans nos restaurants et prédicateur de haine un peu partout
c'est passé par la Turquie et donc on a eu ce phénomène que les États-Unis et la France
avaient décidé de renverser le gouvernement de Bachar Al-Assad
c'est le plan de recolonialisation du Moyen-Orient, après la Libye c'était la Syrie puis le Hamas, le Hezbollah
et il voulait l'Iran mais ce sera plus difficile, en tout cas la résistance Palestinienne il faut la priver de tout ses arrières
et donc cette opération là, ça a été en fait , étant donné que les USA, Obama a compris
l'échec de Bush, il n'est plus question d'envoyer des troupes US au sol comme en Irak, Afghanistan
ça coute cher, on en sort pas, on devient une cible, donc on fait la guerre par proxywork comme ils disent en anglais
c'est-à-dire par intermédiaire, ça peut être des pays voisins ou des mouvements sécessionnistes
ça ça marche parfois mais en Syrie y avait pas les forces pour faire ça donc les seules forces qu'ils ont trouvé
c'est de constituter une armée d'euro-djihadistes, quand même 35000
venus de toute une série de pays avec l'argent de l'Arabie Saoudite et du Qatar pour financer ça
et c'est pas nouveau, c'est exactement ce qui avait été fait contre l’Afghanistan, l'opération Ben Laden
Zbigniew Brzezinski dont je parle l'avait organisé et c'est en fait une opération Ben Laden bis
donc quand j'ai dis que Fabius et compagnie étaient responsables des attentats de Paris, c'est parce qu'en fait
ces gens qui ont fait cela, ont été envoyés en Syrie pour faire ça contre la population Syrienne
parce qu'on massacre des Chrétiens, des Musulmans, donc c'est le boomerang, c'est Frankestein
- Comment voyez-vous les 30 prochaines années ? Sur le prisme de lecture terroriste ?
De cette grande nébuleuse terroriste ?
- Sur le plan du terrorisme je pense que c'est devenu une arme privilégiée des États-Unis,
et de leurs alliés, mais ce sont les USA qui sont le maître d'oeuvre là-dedans, Pourquoi ?
Parce que comme je le disais, les États-Unis n'osent plus envoyer leurs troupes occuper un pays comme ils le faisait avant
ils s'exposent, ça coûte cher, ça soude la population contre eux donc ce n'est pas productif
donc on est obligé de trouver des remplacements, alors évidemment ils ont essayé aussi
de faire en sorte que les Européens se battent pour eux et financent une partie de leur guerre, ça marche moyen
donc on essaye de trouver des puissances locales, parfois ça marche, Israël évidemment ils vivent sur
l'industrie de guerre, donc Israel ne demande que ça, la Colombie était aussi l'Israel de l'Amerique Latine
on va dire, l'Ethiopie aussi dans la corne de l'Afrique une région stratégique
c'est aussi un pays qui sert de "flic" local on va dire aux USA, mais il y a des limites à cela
aussi, et donc maintenant le terrorisme c'est vraiment une arme privilégiée, et c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est un psychiatre célèbre en France qui s'appelle Boris Cyrulnik, il a fait une déclaration très peu de temps après l'attentat
contre Charlie qui était très significative, on lui demandait j'imagine en tant que psychiatre
qu'il a du avoir des jeunes ou des familles de jeunes qui sont venus le voir en étant partis la bas
et moi j'ai rencontré des mamans dont les gosses sont partis et je peux vous dire que c'est vraiment humainement
quelque chose d'horrible à entendre et donc Cyrulnik à rencontré des gens, il a été révolté par
la façon de parler de l'histoire de Charlie en noyant le poisson et en ne parlant pas des vrais problèmes
qui est responsable de cette chose la et si le journaliste lui disait, Cyrulnik disait : ce sont des filières très organisées
qui recrutent les jeunes avec un lavage de cerveau, ça je l'ai vu aussi les méthodes qu'ils emploient pour prendre des jeunes de 15-16 nas
qui sont en adolescence, paumés, c'est facile de manipuler et donc Cyrulnik disait
c'est des filières très organisées, le journaliste, de qui ? Il dit, par les gens du pétrole et de la drogue très clairement
parce que c'est un moyen pas cher pour déstabiliser un gouvernement et controler des régions et des ressources
donc je crois que c'est ça le point fondamental, c'est que le gouvernement francais et ses alliés
ne sont pas la solution face aux problèmes du terrorisme, ils sont la cause du problème, et les États-Unis qui
évidemment les maitres d’œuvres, sont ceux qui utilisent à grande échelle le terrorisme
faut rappeler qu'il l'ont fait contre Cuba, le Venezuela, des pays latino-américain
on a financé les coûts de la CIA pour faire exploser un avion avec des sportifs Cubains
ou dans des hôtels à la Havane, ils se sont réfugiés à Miami les gens qui ont fait cela.
- Est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler des réseaux Gladio ?
- Les réseaux Gladio pour les jeunes c'est un phénomène très important dans les années 50
au moment de la guerre froide, j'ai vécu ça j'etais petit garçon, on était éduqués dans : "Les Russes vont nous attaquer,
Les Russes vont envahir l'Europe et on va tous être obligés de devenir communistes,
de parler Russe, on va perdre nos maisons, nos voitures, on devra partager les femmes, ...".
On était vraiment sur des trucs incroyables, sur la propagande,
et donc l'OTAN a organisé des réseaux pour le cas ou il y aurait des gouvernements de gauche
qui viendraient en Europe, c'était surtout la France et l'Italie, la Belgique aussi
parce que après les années 40-45, le capitalisme a produit la 2 ème guerre mondiale
les patrons en France ont beaucoup collaboré avec le nazisme, en Belgique ils se sont réfugiés à Londres en attendant que ce soit fini
ou ont collaboré à Bruxelles aussi et donc les gens ont compris que la Guerre mondiale est le produit du capitalisme
en tant que lutte pour la suprématie mondiale, les matières premières, les colonies, que c'est une guerre pour le fric
et les réseaux Gladio c'est au cas ou les gens décideraient qu'ils veulent un gouvernement de gauche
avec des communistes, on va faire des attentats, on va déstabiliser le pays
on va semer la terreur, il y a eu des attentats à la gare de Bologne avec 280-300 morts
on a mis des bombes et on a dit c'est des anarchistes et donc ca sert à faire passer des lois répréssives
contre la gauche et en réalité ça a été reconnu par un organisateur de l'attentat
en réalité c'était une provocation du réseau Gladio et de l'OTAN pour semer le bordel en Italie
flanquer la trouille, on revient sur ce qu'on a dit toute à l'heure, aux Italiens
"Allez il faut un gouvernement de droite et des lois très fortes." Donc c'est le recour au terrorisme pour destabiliser
- Vous avez vu, récemment en France une grande campagne contre les théorie du complot, les complotistes
les casques en aluminium, est-ce que vous pensez que, puisque notre histoire n'est pas assez énoncée clairement
comme les réseaux Gladio, que les gens ne savent pas cela, cette antériorité historique qui est utilisée par
ce que nous nous appelons les nouveaux gourous, les réseaux Gladio ils nous l'ont mis à l'envers
les attentats Coulibaly c'est la même chose, nous on est pas du tout daccord avec cette vision la, l'histoire
le rétroviseur qui passe du noir à l'argent mais c'était pas la bonne voiture, on n'est pas trop d'accord avec cela
même pas du tout, est ce que vous pensez que pour supprimer certaines théorie du complot
il faudrait se retourner sur notre passé pour expliquer aux gens, ca s'est produit
mais la sur ce coup la ce n'est pas le cas, qu'en pensez vous ?
Tout à fait, je pense que la question du complot, du complotisme, des obsédés de la théorie du complot
c'est une question importante, je suis en train de travailler la dessus et ça va sortir bientot
en fait il faut dire : 1) que les complots ca existent, je veux dire quand les États-Unis organisent le renversement d'Allende
pour le remplacer par le fasciste Pinochet, oui c'est un complot
ça existe sur le plan politique, économique, militaire. Quand Bush et Blair disent faut attaquer Sadam
parce qu'ils a des armes de destructions massives et qu'ils savent que c'est faux c'est un complot
c'est la définition du dictionnaire. 2ème il faut dire que l’histoire ne se résume pas à des complots
et c'est même pas l'essentiel, tout à l'heure j'ai essayé d'expliquer que le système économique et social dans lequel on vit
il est injuste parce qu'il est basé sur le fait que les 1% décident de ce qu'on va produire dans les usines et ailleurs
de comment l'économie va être organisé, qui va avoir de l'argent qui ne va pas en avoir, mais ca ce n'est pas un complot
c'est des règles de fonctionnement économique, et c'est pas quelque chose qu'ils contrôlent vraiment
Et c'est quelque chose que vous voyez avec vos yeux d'ancien militant communiste ou des choses comme ca ? Vous avez une vision de gauche.
C'est clair que l'analyse de Marx, permet de comprendre comment fonctionne l'économie, et je pense qu'il faut éviter
les lancers d'étiquettes
- C''est ce qu'il y a marqué sur votre fiche Wikipédia
- Ah oui bien sûr
Non mais ce soit a propos de moi ou de n'importe qui, je n'ai pas honte, je crois qu'il faur réfléchir avec son cerveau
et on a intérêt à ce qu'un public large se pose des questions sur comment fonctionne l'économie,
comment fonctionne la politique, comment se décident les guerres,
et aussi étudier l'histoire qui permet énormèmement de comprendre l'époque actuelle.
Donc, sans les étiquettes, oui je pense que l'économie,
Marx a très bien expliqué comment ça se fait qu'il y en a qui sont très riches,
il y en a qui sont très pauvres et qu'il y a un lien entre les deux.
C'est des vases communiquants
Hugo, avant Marx, ou en même temps,
je crois pas qu'ils se connaissaient,
avait dit : "C'est de l'enfer des pauvres qu'est fait le paradis des riches".
Donc c'est un bon résumé de l'exploitation.
Et ... je crois que ... il faut pas expliquer ça en termes de complot ...
qu'il y a quelques personnes, des banquiers, ou des juifs, ou des illuminatis ...
qui sont dans une cave et qui décident qu'on va faire une crise, comme ça, des choses pareilles.
Ca c'est du fantasme.
Et on voit beaucoup de fantasmes et de théories du complot pour expliquer le Monde
pour une raison bien simple : c'est que les médias ne permettent pas de comprendre le Monde,
les médias cachent à chaque guerre la vérité,
cachent le fonctionnement de l'économie, je veux dire ...
On invite tout le temps des économistes qui serinent que le 1 % a raison et qu'il y a pas d'alternatives,
et tous les autres sont boycottés
donc évidemment que les gens se posent des questions.
Comme ils n'ont pas la réponse ils vont chercher sur Internet
Sur Internet on peut trouver de bonnes choses et de moins bonnes,
et forcément, ils peuvent tomber dans des pièges.
Et c'est très important, effectivement d'étudier l'histoire,
mais aussi l'économie, les stratégies de guerre,
parce que moi je pense que souvent on dit :
"Ces trucs là c'est trop compliqué, les gens vont pas comprendre"
donc on simplifie. Non ! Il faut essayer de communiquer l'essentiel,
de donner des faits, de permettre aux gens de réfléchir,
dans un langage simple, avec des mots que tout le monde comprend,
et tout le monde peut comprendre.
Moi j'ai déjà donné des formations sur l'économie, ou la philosophie, ou les stratégies de guerre,
à des ouvriers qui avait arrêté les études à 16 ans.
A des ménagères, qui avaient jamais fait d'études.
Et donc tout le monde peut comprendre ça et je vais dire :
les gens d'en-bas parfois comprendront beaucoup mieux le fond des choses
que les gens qui croient qu'avec leur grande éducation ils savent tout.
Et je crois que c'est ça, pour répondre à cette histoire du complot,
les médias n'informant pas,
refusant le débat avec les gens qui défendent d'autre points de vues, une autre analyse
ou d'autres sources, tout simplement, qu'eux,
ils provoquent ce sentiment "On nous cache tout" donc on va chercher des choses, midi à quatorze heures,
alors que ... le Monde est parfaitement connaissable, et analysable, s'il y a une vraie info correcte
Et c'est ça qu'avec Investig'Action on essaye de faire :
donner aux citoyens les moyens eux-mêmes d'analyser le Monde et de se faire leur opinion.
- Vous avez parlé des Balkans, on va revenir sur les Balkans. Est-ce que vous connaissez le général Wesley Clark ?
- Bien sûr.
- Est-ce que vous connaissez ses déclarations ?
- Aah oui ! Je les ai citées dans ...
- Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ? Qui est ce monsieur ? Et ... qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
- Bein, Wesley Clark est un général qui a bombardé la Yougoslavie et j'étais sur place pendant le bombardements
- Il était chef d'état-major.
- Il était le chef de l'état-major de l'OTAN, donc c'était le chef des opérations,
et je peux témoigner que c'est un criminel de guerre, que s'il y avait une justice internationale, il aurait dû être jugé.
parce que j'étais sur place, j'ai vu des hôpitaux bombardés,
j'ai vu qu'ils étaient venus bombarder un hôpital, j'ai vu ... une infirmière, en entendant les sirènes,
elle s'est dit "Je suis en congés, mais ma place est à l'hôpital", elle arrive à l'hôpital,
ILS REVIENNENT bombarder une deuxième fois. Pas bombarder, je veux dire, avec des bombes à fragmentation.
Donc elle a été amputé... C'était vraiment terrible, j'ai vu des gosses...
j'ai vu des usines détruites, comme par hasard,
toutes les usines qui étaient nationalisées yougoslaves ont été détruites,
et toutes les usines qui appartenaient à des multinationales étrangères, celles-là étaient intactes.
Donc c'était vraiment une guerre économique dégueulasse
et Wesley Clarke était un criminel de guerre, ça c'est clair.
Ca donne d'autant plus de poids ... à la déclaration très intéressante qu'il a faite
en 2005 ou en 2007, je ne sais plus, je crois 2005,
il était interviewé par une radio que je connais, où j'avais été, qui s'appelle "Democraty Now",
par Amy Goodman aux États-Unis,
et il a fait une confidence très intéressante.
Il était à la retraite toute de suite après la Yougoslavie,
et donc il s'amène au Pentagone fin 2001, après le 11septembre,
novembre décembre, je crois, il y a la date dans un de mes bouquins
et il rencontre un général avec qui il était copain.
et ce général lui dit : "Voilà, je viens de recevoir un mémo d'en haut (donc de Donald Rumsfeld, le ministre de la guerre)
et le mémo dit : Nous allons, nous États-Unis, nous allons prendre 7 pays
en commencant par l'Irak, l'Afghanistan, le Soudan,
la Libye, le Liban, la Somalie et pour finir l'Iran."
Sept pays. En 2001. Donc, ça veut dire que tout ça était programmé.
Après on dit "Oui c'est parce que Saddam a des armes de destruction massive, parce que le Soudan ils font ceci ou ils font ça
ou Khadafi... ". C'est tout programmé, et après on saute sur le prétexte, ou on fabrique le prétexte.
Et donc Wesley Clarke c'était un aveu très intéressant, parce que, c'est pas un type de gauche,
c'est pas un complotiste, il dit lui-même "Voilà, les États-Unis ils ont un plan
pour recoloniser tout le monde arabo-musulman",
et ça on l'a analysé dans un bouquin qui s'appelle "La Stratégie du Chaos - Impérialisme & Islam".
Les États-Unis décident de controler ce qu'ils appellent "L'arc islamique" :
Moyen-Orient, Maghreb, mais aussi la corne de l'Afrique avec deux pays stratégiques,
le Soudan et la Somalie, et l'Afghanistan et le Pakistan qui sont,
l'Afghanistan c'est la plaque tournante au point de vue stratégique de l'Asie,
pour menacer la Chine, et le Pakistan c'est la zone centrale pour les voies de l'Océan Indien,
parce qu'on pense toujours en termes de pays au niveau stratégique mais il faut penser en termes d'océans,
les zones maritimes il y en a 60 % maintenant qui sont dans l'Océan Indien,
c'est plus l'Atlantique ou même le Pacifique, c'est l'Océan Indien qui est le centre du monde.
et donc le Pakistan, voilà.
- Vous connaissez le "collier de perles" ?
- Oui c'est ça.
- La sécurisation du "collier de perles".
- Oui voilà. Les Chinois ayant peu de matières premières et une économie qui se développe énormèment,
sont obligés de se procurer des matières premières là où il y en a.
Et donc c'est par là que les États-Unis veulent les tenir.
Évidemment les États-Unis ne sont pas tout à fait fous et ils ne peuvent pas imaginer
d'attaquer militairement la Chine, ça serait impossible.
Donc il faut l'encercler. Il faut la priver ou pouvoir la priver de ses approvisionnements en matières premières,
Donc il y a une guerre pour les matières premières et ce que la Chine veut faire
c'est un réseau de ports en eaux profondes,
parce que le commerce maritime international maintenant c'est des ports en eaux profondes,
Et voilà, tout ce "collier de perles" effectivement, toute cette chaîne de ports en eaux profondes,
les États-Unis, dès qu'il y a un partenaire ou un allié pour la Chine ils essayent de déstabiliser :
coup d'état, guerre civile, ou corruption pour essayer de prendre le contrôle.
Ils l'ont fait récemment au Sri-Lanka et c'est vraiment très important pour eux de contrôler l'Océan Indien.
- La Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée, qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire en ce moment ?
- Je suis pas spécialiste, je passe.
- D'accord.
- Comment ça va se terminer ?
- Sur le plan des guerres, sur le plan du terrorisme ou en général ?
- Sur le plan des guerres, ouais.
Parce que là on voit la Russie faire énormément de mouvements,
on voit la Chine construire des porte-avions fixes avec des îles artificielles,
on voit les contrats d'armement, les alliances se souder un peu à gauche et à droite,
nous l'Europe on est au milieu, comment ça va se terminer ? On va à la guerre ou on va pas à la guerre ?
- Personne peut le prédire... L'histoire n'est pas prévisible sur ce plan là. Les deux peuvent arriver.
Il y a toute une série de ... J'ai publié, il y a quelques mois,
une série d'articles, "Obama craint un conflit mondial", je crois que c'était ça le titre,
analysant un discours très étonnant qu'il a fait,
au moment où il a présenté l'accord conclu avec l'Iran.
Il avait évidemment une opposition très forte des Républicains au sein du Congrès, même chez les Démocrates aussi,
qui disait : "Il faut pas faire un accord avec l'Iran, il faut les attaquer. Il faut continuer."
Et il a dit, Obama, "si vous attaquez l'Iran,
1) ça va pas du tout faire le bien des États-Unis, parce que l'Iran nous résiste,
il s'est pas mis à genoux,
2) ça va nous discréditer au point de vue international,
jusqu'à présent on a pu compter sur l'aide de la France et des Européens pour faire la guerre contre la Libye ou la Syrie,
mais si on fait ça tout seul, étant donné que Peugeot et compagnie ne rêvent que d'une chose c'est des contrats de Téhéran
ils vont pas nous suivre, c'est fini, les Allemands non plus n'en veulent pas".
Donc il a dit à ses opposants aux États-Unis : "Il faut arrêter de penser qu'on peut faire la guerre contre l'Iran".
Et il a dit aussi une chose intéressante, il a dit :
"On va pas pouvoir contrer comme ça la volonté des Russes et des Chinois indéfiniment" ;
les Chinois ils possèdent une grande partie de la dette des États-Unis,
parce que l'état des États-Unis est un état en faillite,
s'il n'y a pas les pétro-monarchies et la Chine pour financer sa dette, l'économie est en faillite, littéralement.
Et donc, il a dit : "Voilà ! Si on fait ça, on va affaiblir terriblement les États-Unis".
Alors on se trouve maintenant dans une période histoire très importante et très dangeureuse.
En fait, il y a deux courants aux États-Unis. Il y a le courant qui dit :
"Nous sommes en déclin, économiquement, financièrement, militairement,
il faut essayer d'être malin, il faut faire des guerres sans que cela ne se voit trop,
il faut toujours avoir des alliés, il faut essayer de neutraliser les puisances qui pourraient s'opposer,
il faut faire la guerre intelligemment,
ça veut dire aussi par la corruption, par la CIA, par des guerres civiles,
et de la façon la moins visible possible." Ca c'est un courant.
C'est Obama, c'est Brzezinski, des gens comme ça.
L'autre courant, c'est le courant "néo-con" on va dire, Bush,
mais Hillary Clinton elle est plutôt de ce courant là, il faut pas croire, c'est pas "républicains ou démocrates".
- Et Bernie Sanders il est comment là-dedans ?
- Ah oui, non là ... Je pense que je voterais pour lui aux États-Unis si j'étais là.
Mais je veux dire que, les "néo-con" ont un plan,
que au contraire il faut aller à la confrontation avec la Russie, qu'il faut pas laisser faire Poutine,
et donc on le provoque. On est en train de le provoquer de toutes les manières, pour essayer de faire une escalade,
et les "néo-con" sont décidés à faire ce qu'il faut pour briser la résistance de la Russie, de la Chine, de l'Iran bien entendu.
Ils nous emmènent faire une troisième guerre mondiale. Pas programmée ou voulue,
mais quand on lance une escalade contre d'autres puissances de cette manière là,
quand on refuse de négocier ou de trouver des solutions diplomatiques,
c'est clair que ça peut mener sur un conflit épouvantable.
- Les préconisations pour éviter le "conflit épouvantable" ?
La chose qui manque terriblement en Europe et aux États-Unis, mais bon je vais parler en tant qu'Européen,
c'est un mouvement anti-guerre.
Il y a eu des manifestations, j'en parlais, avec des millions de gens dans le Monde
contre la guerre du Vietnam, encore en 2003 contre la guerre en Irak,
mais, à part ça, quand les États-Unis ou la France attaquent un pays,
que ce pays soit une démocratie ou une dictature, ça ne change rien, puisque c'est une guerre pour le fric.
Quand on attaque des pays, quand on fait la guerre, il n'y a personne dans les rues maintenant.
c'est ça qui est dramatique, c'est que ...
On a eu dans le passé des mouvements anti-guerre puissants, dans les années 30,
dans les années 50,
et encore après. on a eu des dockers qui refusaient de charger les armements,
on a eu des ouvriers qui se mettaient en grève, on a eu des sabotages de trains, on a eu ...
des mouvements de solidarité très importants, on a eu des appels d'intellectuels pour la Paix,
des réunions, des forums, Bertrand Russell, des tribnaux, tout ça,
et maintenant c'est complètement disparu,
et il y a un phénomène terrible en France et dans les autres pays Européens, c'est que la gauche qui devrait,
je parle pas de Mr hollande, ça c'est pas la gauche pour moi,
mais même à gauche du PS, les gens qui devraient être en premiere ligne contre la guerre,
pour la paix, pour le dialogue international, pour le respect de la souveraineté des nations,
basculent, et soutiennent les guerres de l'OTAN, en disant "Oui il faut faire quelques chose,
là il y a un dictateur, là il ya ceci là il y a cela".
Comme si le but des États-Unis et de la France était d'amener la démocratie partout dans le monde,
ils font ça avec l'aide de l'Arabie Saoudite et du Qatar donc forcèment ils se payent la gueule des gens.
Donc je crois que ça c'est le drame maintenant.
La gauche a totalement capitulé devant les guerres que j'appelle coloniales,
n'osent plus dire qu'on nous ment à chaque guerre,
et n'osent plus organiser la solidarité avec les pays du Sud.
Et là, on revient à cette phrase de Debray que je cite tout le temps :
il y a une mentalité coloniale, une mentalité arrogante, en France et en Europe,
"Nous les Blancs, les Bons, on sait ce qu'il faut faire partout dans le Monde,
on sait ce que les Arabes, les Africains et les Latinois doivent faire",
mais non ! Pourquoi on saurait plus qu'eux ?
Pourquoi on aurait la solution ? Laissez les se  débrouiller pour résoudre leur problèmes !
Et ça, l'absence d'un mouvement anti-guerre, pour moi c'est une chose terrible parce que
comme je le disais, on EST sur le sentier de la guerre,
ça PEUT arriver, ce n'est pas une fatalité,
mais la résistance...elle est où ?
- Dernière question, un conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Pour endurcir l'esprit critique ?
- Oui, ça c'est l'essentiel. Je crois que ... la jeune génération
a vraiment intérêt, si elle veut vivre dans un monde qui soit pas épouvantable
au niveau des guerres, de la destruction de la Nature,
et de cette manière de répandre la haine, que tout le monde se déteste dans tous les sens,
je crois que la jeune génération a vraiment intérêt à prendre en main
son combat, pour la Justice, pour la Paix, pour la Nature,
et que le combat il passe par la question de l'info.
Et donc Investig'Action c'est de ça qu'on s'occupe, on est un média,
c'est ça notre "métier" on va dire.
Il n'est pas possible de faire la guerre sans manipuler les gens.
Donc il est très important de vérifier les infos,
et, je parle de guerre déclarée ou non-déclarée,
de guerre militaire ou de guerre sociale ou culturelle, etc,
Il faut vérifier les infos absolument. Et c'est tout à fait possible.
Il faut que l'info devienne quelque chose qui n'est pas réservé aux experts ou aux professionnels,
mais devienne une activité citoyenne. C'est trop important
l'info pour notre vie aujourd'hui et demain à tous
pour la laisser aux mains de gens pour qui c'est soit du fric soit des intérêts de propagande,
il faut que l'info soit faite par les citoyens, je pense quqe ça devrait commencer à l'école mais là, je rêve
et donc il faut organiser des ateliers parallèles, ou avec les profs qui sont motivés là-dessus,
mais en parallèle, il faut organiser des ateliers pour apprendre à regarder la télé ou les images,
les manipulations que ça peut entraîner, pour apprendre à faire une analyse critique sur les infos qu'on reçoit,
à chercher les sources, à écouter l'autre version, à écouter les méchants,
et à se faire son opinion par soi-même. Je pense que, c'est quelque chose que je dis très souvent,
- C'est qui les méchants ?
- Bein les méchants c'est toujours ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec nous,
ceux qui sont pas d'accord de donner le pétrole gratuitement, ou le cuivre, ou le coltane,
ou le canal de Suez ou le canal de Panama,
les méchants c'est ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec le 1% des multinationales,
c'est ceux-là qui sont diabolisés.
Et donc je crois que si on veut, vraiment, comme je le dis
créer un Monde, et je pense vraiment que c'est possible, quand je sais pas,
mais je pense vraiment que c'est possible,
créer un Monde où il n'y aura plus l'exploitation et tous les uns contre les autres,
et la haine et la destruction de la Nature,
je pense que l'info est la première des batailles,
et c'est pour ça que je le premier conseil que je donne, aux jeunes et à tout le monde,
c'est d'appliquer cette idée, prendre en main la bataille de l'info,
c'est-à-dire : Nous sommes tous des journalistes.
- Michel Collon, merci.
- Merci à vous.
(Musique du générique)